manik vous l'avez vu malik bentalha il
est de plus en plus beaux noms et en
tapant son nom sur google images non
parce qu'on va taper le tient après 0
non trop
j'ai un ami tu es mon frère witternesse
jusqu'à la mi temps au dessus d'un ami
je le dis voilà aux téléspectateurs
alors pour mieux se repérer dans le
temps on a réalisé une frise de toi
arrête s'te plaît tu va coûter de plus
en plus beau alors regardez comme il est
mignon c'est l'autre cyril avec manny
québécois à regarder on commence avec
mme annick regardez regardez c'est ma
ligne je te bouffe de bouffe vous le
bouffer après malik tout son clan penny
regarde regardez comme il est et moi je
lui dirai billy crawford et moi mais il
est trop mignon huit jours et je vais
m'assurer jour en place j'aurais pas
lâcher ne devrait pas lâcher ni appareil
des tweaks voilà au caresser ses tracks
la gt surfer à l'époque
c'est en fait sur des babouches c'est en
fait s'en détacher le policier
j'avais un ukulélé tout dira tahitien
ouais ouais c'est vrai
le tahitien qui change avec ce à quoi
bon sauveur de rainbow qui a mis du
temps à arriver et on y est
il est reparti mais allez on passe à
autre chose ma fille et moi c'est pas le
collier le problème moi sa famille c'est
quoi vous le setca pas de coups alors ma
première mama mama photo préférée au
numéro un ton premier set filles de
stars away regarde olala ouais il assez
chaude et rationnelle salah les forêts
dans ma voiture mon nature non alors tu
étais pas mal de promesses elle fit sa
manie de son décès fait qu'un joueur du
psg c'est exactement c'est beau
supporters du psg là mais en fait c'est
toi qui prenait le cette vie exactement
oui avec un kodak regarder et elles à
kristen bell à temps des salaires après
manic regarder ce changement c'est un
truc de ouf réalise bon batman des
années si elle paraît j'aime pas être
regardés et là après il a refait son cv
il a fait bep compta c'est le mec on
croit qu'il est une pizzeria d'un
restaurant italien
on sait que les algériens
il s'appelle 36 ce groupe après tes pour
les très beaux malik bentalha et très
beau c'est ce qui m'a retenir ce soir je
vais regarder d'autres photos alesi
autrement dit mon dimanche à roland
garros avec à la cause que t'as pas
acheter quoi que je devais rendre après
d'allocations après la photo direct
après la fois pris la photo monsieur
c'est fallait regarder permet à regarder
après on a dénoté pas lé toit en toit et
du scénar quoi tu dois mais sa tête est
comme le bon vin
franchement malik bentalha canada ajax
est décédé ouais c'est vrai et cyril
binot et vendredi lors à 30 ans pendant
le prime de drm les années 2000 a
exactement et pendant le prime qui aura
30 au situant dans une vidéo hommage
bien sûr je te ferai une dent dure de ré
pour tous les gens qui ont disparu
dommage de vous bien sûr et après bien
entendu je serai à ton anniversaire à
j'espère tu sais les tags gourmand cmh
mange à ce jeu c'est quoi disons que tu
fais tu vois que tu crois que tu es chez
toi mais tu crois qu'il a un repas de
famille
non un petit mot parce que nos deux on
était dans le même club de sport dont je
voyais l'évolution est donc aussi dans
les vestiaires et puis forcément on a
toujours un qui veut bouger un petit peu
ouais j'ai regardé un petit peu le petit
cuit tout ça et je voyais vraiment comme
il était en train de se dessiner est
vraiment comme il est devenu beau gosse
connais pas cette personne des douches
calme toi ça va parce que c'était
souvient de tout voilà c'était des bons
souvenirs
c'est la très très beau mais